[Музика]
привіт, привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звуть Нутелла, давайте почнемо
сьогодні ми поговоримо про гаджети
та соціальні мережі, давайте підемо на
попередньому уроці ми говорили про
Інтернет,
що ми можемо зробити в Інтернеті, давайте
подивимося  біля дошки і перевірте слова,
які фільми вивчають чи йога слухати
музику робити покупки, знаходити інформацію грати в
ігри обмінюватися фотографіями поспілкуватися з друзями
та перевіряти новини, що з цього ми можемо
робити онлайн подумайте про це чи можемо ми вивчати
онлайн чи можемо ми мати урок йоги  можливо,
тепер я думаю, що всі ці відповіді
правильні, тому що якщо ви хочете займатися йогою,
ви можете провести онлайн-урок зі своєю
вчителькою за допомогою програми, і вона
проводить урок і на своєму місці, а ви
маєте урок вдома, і у вас є
урок  ви займаєтеся йогою чи можете ви робити
покупки в Інтернеті, звичайно,
ви відвідуєте магазин, ви замовляєте товари
і маєте доставку зі своїм
пакетом знайдіть інформацію, грайте в ігри,
звичайно, перевіряйте новини, тому насправді  всі
ці відповіді правильні, давайте перейдемо далі,
тому гаджети подивіться на картинку, у нас
є шість гаджетів і у нас є шість назв,
але давайте назвемо їх так, щоб номер а
перше зображення що це було ноутбук
це не ноутбук це інше
, тому повторіть  за мною ноутбук номер
два картинка B що це цифрова
камера ні телевізор з плоским екраном ні що
це це mp3-плеєр
повторюй за мною mp3-плеєр номер
три або картинка дивись що це це
ігрова консоль це
відеоігрова консоль  picture DI, здогадуюсь,
усі ви знаєте відповідь так, це
смартфон, а наступна камера,
яка камера, подивіться на
слово, що цифрова камера повторює за мною
цифровий фотоапарат, а останній — телевізор з
плоским екраном, давайте  рухайся далі, так що
ми можемо зробити зі смартфоном, ми можемо робити
багато речей, тому що це універсальний
гаджет, давайте подивимося на ці
фрази, щоб ми могли відіслати віч-на-
віч, хм, не працює, мабуть, надсилати телефонні дзвінки
, але я  я не впевнений, w  ми
можемо надсилати електронні листи та
текстові повідомлення добре, що ми можемо зробити, чи можемо
ми створити соціальні мережі Я не думаю, що
ми можемо зателефонувати це правильно, а
як щодо Чета Чета Чета,
можливо  чат онлайн Я не
знаю, ми подивимося,
як ми можемо продовжити, йти в
соціальних мережах, схоже, це звучить
дуже приємно, і давайте подивимося на
ці два слова, які використовуємо та говоримо, що ми
говоримо, ми насправді використовуємо  мова, яку ми
говоримо устами, але іноді ми
використовуємо мову тіла, я використовую
жести, тому я використовую мову жестів і
розмовляю чим ми можемо говорити ми говоримо
мовою, але ми також говоримо з людьми,
а іноді ми не спілкуємося в Інтернеті  ми
говоримо віч-на-віч перед
людиною,
тож давайте перевіримо готовність, давайте подивимося,
деякі електронні листи надсилають листи чи надсилають текстові
повідомлення робити телефонні дзвінки в чаті онлайн переходьте
в соціальні мережі, використовуйте мову жестів та спілкуйтеся
віч-на-віч, тепер відповідайте на мене
запитайте, як часто ви робите ці
речі, і ми можемо використовувати прислівники
частота цегла madnikey просто
бездумний чай як часто ти робиш
те,
як часто ти спілкуєшся в Інтернеті
я особисто спілкуюся в Інтернеті кожен день, тому
я можу сказати, що я завжди спілкуюся онлайн, як часто
ти ходиш у соціальні мережі о, я завжди ходжу
в соціальних мережах  Я залежу від соціальних
мереж, а як щодо вас, як часто ви ходите
в соціальні мережі та як часто ви
користуєтеся мовою жестів, хм, я б сказав, що особисто я зазвичай користуюся мовою жестів,
тому що я дуже емоційний і
мені подобається використовувати мову тіла.  використання
жестів добре, як часто ти говориш
лицем до лиця, багато людей зараз кажуть,
що вони майже ніколи не розмовляють віч-на-віч,
але це залежить, звичайно,
чи мої друзі за кордоном.
у вас є друзі за кордоном, давайте перейдемо далі,
давайте подивимося на ці фотографії,
щоб ви могли згадати, що
робити в Інтернеті або в соціальних
мережах, давайте подивимося номер один,
що ви думаєте, що це таке, хм,
так це G, надішліть миттєво  безлад  вік, що
щодо наступного, це цей знак, тому я
використовую мову жестів, що це таке - як
допис чи фотографія так правильно,
як часто лайкайте дописи Мені подобаються дописи
щодня
Мені подобаються публікації потік номерів що
це
добре, це переглянути  профіль, тож у вас
є людина, і ви перевіряєте інформацію
про цю людину ви
сфотографували особисту інформацію місце
проживання цієї людини і, ймовірно, деякі
цікаві факти про цю людину
номер чотири так це завантажте нову
фотографію або додайте фотографію до  пост поділіться ним
зі світом і номер п'ять, ви хочете
більше друзів, люди приєднуйтесь до мене, я
хочу більше друзів, тому я надсилаю запит на
дружбу, я надсилаю запит на дружбу,
так, проблеми з Наруто
номер шість, у нас тут є два слова  і
це твіти та ретвіти допис, що
це за твіт, щоб розмістити інформацію або
завантажити інформацію та ретвітити
це поділитися інформацією, яку хтось
сказав вам це, і ви хочете поділитися нею
з іншими
номер сім поділіться al  чорнила, подивіться, я
виявив інтерес до фактів або я знайшов
дійсно цікаві статті, я хочу
поділитися цим з вами, а ви поділіться посиланням
і номером вісім завантажте файл або
фотографію, щоб до фотографії ви могли додати фотографію
або завантажити фотографію за допомогою  файл що
ви можете зробити ви можете додати файл або завантажити
файл давайте перевіримо зараз
надіслати миттєве повідомлення повторити за мною,
як допис або як фотографію переглянути
профіль додати фотографію до публікації надіслати запит на
дружбу твіти або ретвіти публікацію
поділіться a  посилання завантажте файл або фотографію
зараз є завдання для вас
подивіться тут є шість картинок
виберіть правильне слово я даю вам 10 секунд,
зараз давайте перевіримо, щоб перша з них завантажила
номер два, наприклад, номер три, номер
чотири
відправити і номер п'ять  поділіться
останнім відправте миттєве повідомлення Браво,
ви все прочитали правильно, зараз я хочу, щоб
ви прочитали текст, і поки ви
читаєте текст, виберіть правильне слово, я
дам вам п’ять секунд,
зараз давайте перевіримо, тому будьте безпечні та
відповідальні в Інтернеті, це в основному
в  правила, як бути в безпеці в Інтернеті,
тому, коли ви використовуєте надсилати вам,
правильна відповідь – переглядати, коли ви переглядаєте
новий профіль у соціальних мережах, завжди
пам’ятайте, що існує щонайменше
двісті сімдесят мільйонів підроблених
, тому переконайтеся, що ви  додайте реальних
людей номер два не приймайте ділитися
або лайкувати запити в друзі,
що правильна правильна відповідь -
приймайте запит в друзі, тому правило таке:
не приймайте запит в друзі, якщо ви не
впевнені, що особа номер три, яка ділиться
цим, додайте його  або пісок це справжнє, тож що є
правильним пісок, давайте подивимося на
правило ще раз, тому не приймайте запит на дружбу,
якщо ви не впевнені, що
особа, яка надіслала його, реальна наступний один
номер чотири говорити твіт ретвітуйте публікацію
що таке  правильний ретвіт, тож і номер
п'ять твіти його переглянуто або чати твіти це
давайте разом перевіримо кімнату, перш ніж ви
ретвітуєте публікацію, хтось твітує це вам
переконайтеся, що це правда, перевірте
інформацію, яка нам потрібна, щоб перевірити
інформацію та будьте чесними, і останній
на  Доступ до завантаження або опублікування електронної пошти,
давайте перевіримо доступ, тому правило полягає в тому, що, коли
ви отримуєте доступ до своєї електронної пошти, не натискайте жодних
посилань, поки не впевнені, від кого вони надійшли
, тому будьте безпечними та відповідальними в Інтернеті,
давайте перейдемо далі. Я хочу, щоб ви додали більше
слова до речень давайте подивимося
введіть завантажте прийміть оновлення та
опублікуйте давайте почнемо з номера один ви можете
lalalala додаток для обміну повідомленнями на телефон
що ви робите з програмою обміну повідомленнями
прийняти оновлення не збігається, тому ви можете
завантажити ви можете завантажити
додаток для обміну повідомленнями на телефон, скільки програм у вас
є на телефоні, у
мене є 20, а як щодо вас 5 10 або,
ймовірно, більше перевірте це зараз
номер 2 це незаконно вводити
в чужий обліковий запис електронної пошти, тому ця
особа хоче ввести чужий
обліковий запис  і ми називаємо цей факт хакерством,
тому зламати чужий
обліковий запис електронної пошти незаконно, не робіть цього, навіть якщо ця
особа дасть вам пароль
, не вводьте чийсь обліковий запис номер
ніколи не лалалала запитайте друзів від
так  хтось, кого ти не знаєш, ти пам'ятаєш це
з попереднього завдання з тексту,
тому правильна відповідь: прийми ніколи не
приймай запит на дружбу від когось, кого
ти не знаєш, а наступний ти
маєш закрити свій профіль, так
як ти"  ви студент коледжу, тому
інформація застаріла, що ви робите
з новою інформацією
так правильно, ви
оновлюєте інформацію, ви повинні оновити свій
профіль, все ще говориться, що ви студент коледжу
номер п’ять, вам потрібно
ла-ля-ля-ля своє ім’я користувача  і пароль
для доступу до вашого облікового запису що ви робите
зі своїм паролем та ім'ям користувача так ви
вводите вам потрібно ввести своє ім'я користувача
та пароль для доступу до вашого облікового запису
і останній про тролів тролів
людей, які публікують неприємні коментарі в Інтернеті,
будь ласка, не співпрацюйте  з ними не
спілкуйся з тролями, це небезпечно,
давайте йти далі, зараз настав час вікторини, і я
збираюся перевірити, чи ви готові, давайте підемо, якщо у
вас проблема з соціальними мережами, ми
дізнаємося дуже скоро, але допоможіть мені з
цим  У кілька днів я ні з ким не спілкуюся
віч-на-віч,
і правильна відповідь - говоріть номер
два. Я надсилаю більше 250 текстових повідомлень
на день, номер три, я більше не телефоную
номер чотири, я заходжу в соціальні мережі, перш
ніж щось робити  ще вранці
й останнє я перевіряю більше з друзями в
Інтернеті, ніж зі своєю сім'єю, зараз давайте
з'ясуємо, чи є у вас якісь соціальні проблеми
чи ні, тому подивіться на ці запитання,
я дам вам десять секунд, щоб подумати про
них і відповісти  питання,
тож давайте відповімо разом я буду
першим, хто відповість на запитання кілька
днів я ні з ким не розмовляю віч-на-
віч,
це неправда про мене, тому моя перша
відповідь: ні, я надсилаю більше 250
текстових повідомлень на день так  це правда
про мене так, номер три, я більше не
телефоную, хм, я все ще
спілкуюся зі своєю мамою, я телефоную їй щодня,
тому я думаю, ні для мене, ні, а що з
тобою, так, я знаю, що номер чотири я заходжу в
соціальні мережі до того, як я  робити щось інше
вранці, іноді дозволяйте m  Я думаю, що,
мабуть, я скажу так, так, і останнє я
перевірив більше з друзями в Інтернеті, ніж
зі своєю сім'єю, це правда, що у мене так багато
друзів по всьому світу, і вони спілкуються
з ними щодня, тому що я хочу
спілкуватися з ними, а вони хочуть
знати  їхні новини, тож для мене так так, зараз
давайте подивимося, скільки так у мене є
один два три, і тест каже, що якщо ви
відповіли так на всі п'ять запитань, у вас
можуть виникнути проблеми, поговоріть з кимось,
ймовірно, психотерапевтом або просто поговоріть
з людьми  різні люди твоїм
друзям до твоєї сім'ї у мене
всього троє я думаю, що я в порядку, а що з
тобою так ще одне завдання для тебе
я люблю тести тому ще один тест для тебе
сьогодні ще раз подивіться на картинки і
швидко виберіть слово десять секунд для
ви і давайте перевіримо завантажити лайк і надіслати
поділіться та надіслати Браво
все правильно як ви віддаєте
перевагу спілкуватися з друзями чи
спілкуєтеся ви онлайн чи віч-на-віч, що
ви віддаєте перевагу давайте подивимося на ці
перегони, які ми починаємо  син, як я
вважаю за краще говорити віч-на-віч, тому що я
дуже соціальний, а
також я багато спілкуюся зі своїми друзями
по всьому світу, і вони спілкуються з ними
онлайн, але ми можемо поговорити по відео,
тому я бачу обличчя, це
цікавіше  для мене, що щодо вас
, ви віддаєте перевагу використовувати мову жестів або
стояти на місці я більше довіряю людям, які використовують
мову жестів, мені здається, що ця
людина більш відкрита, а як щодо надсилання
листів електронною поштою чи текстових повідомлень, ви
все ще надсилаєте листи за допомогою посту
Я не надсилаю електронного листа, якщо це офіційна
ситуація, і вони розмовляють з компанією,
і якщо це приватна розмова, я
просто надсилаю особі текстове повідомлення та надсилаю повідомлення,
так що на сьогодні все, час
для домашнього завдання, у
нас є зображення  з п’яти значків, і ми
маємо п’ять слів, які потрібно позначити на
піктограмах і чарівних малюнках, тому телефонний дзвінок
чат онлайн електронна пошта мовою жестів і текстові
повідомлення на наступному уроці я збираюся перевірити, чи
ви готові, і лунає дзвінок,
на жаль, нам потрібно завершити
урок го  дякую тобі дуже до побачення
[музика]
ти